President Trump goes to Iowa later today
where he will be competing for attention
along with the Democrats 2020
frontrunner that's Joe Biden at O'Keefe
is in the state capitol des Moines right
now ed good morning to you so what can
voters are expect to see today
well good morning Gail former Vice
President Biden is set to level his most
direct attacks yet on President Trump
during three campaign stops across Iowa
today according to excerpts provided by
the Biden campaign the former vice
president is set to tell audiences that
he believes mr. Trump is quote in
existential threat to America he will
call out the president's decision to
start a trade war with China that he
says he's hurting Iowa farmers and he'll
say that the president's recent trip to
Europe was a quote stunning display of
childishness as mr. Trump attacked the
Mayor of London and House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi on Twitter for his part the
president will visit a renewable energy
company in western Iowa before attending
a state GOP fundraiser tonight
in the Des Moines area and what have you
been hearing from Democratic voters
there about the very large field of
candidates sure well look you know
voters here know that they play a big
role in picking presidents the latest
poll here finds that Joe Biden has a
decent lead but not as high as it is in
some national polls with that in mind we
asked a handful of undecided Democrats
what they make of the former vice
president I like Joe Biden I met him
when he was in Sur Mike a few years back
he's a nice
and and he is one of the leaders and I
would consider Joe Biden he's just an
old pair of shoes to me I am and he's
comfortable but I want youth I think
2016 would have been a really great year
for Joe I'm not looking for an old man
that is over the age of 60 that has had
their chance to do things we just need
some new ideas new energy this will be
Biden's only second visits of the
Hawkeye State is declared presidential
candidate Massachusetts senator
Elizabeth Warren has made eight stops
here South Bend Indiana mayor Pete budda
judge has made five and that's partly
why they're beginning to surge in polls
Warren of course gets credit for having
plenty of detailed policy proposals and
Democrats tell us the largest operation
here in the state meanwhile pollsters
say voters are telling them that mayor
Pete is simply a fresh face that they're
looking for Tony all right thank you
very much pretty harsh we're still
stinging from the comment the old man at
the age of 60 did you just say an old
man over they just say that hurt a
little bit well you know we're not hurt
lady that hurt we will address that
further in the show yeah we're gonna be
talking about the definition of elderly